hey youtubers it's Charlie and here's my
Game of Thrones Season 4 preview for
Jaime Lannister
but first I have a very special
announcement as of today I'm now a
partner at Nerdist Alliance they're just
going to help me win the Iron Throne of
YouTube you heard it here first
I claim rights to make a show called
game of YouTube's you upload or you die
now on to Jaime like I did in my Tyrion
preview here's full disclosure on
spoilers since I'm mostly talking about
the way the characters are developing
from seasons 3 to seasons four I won't
reference specific events so consider
that your spoiler warning for seasons
and books 1 through 3 so let's do this
so one of the reasons why I like Jaime
Lannister so much is that he spends the
first couple books in the first couple
seasons being fairly irredeemable
there's all these big earth-shattering
things happening in the East Dragons are
being reborn Dany is mounting an army
against Westeros another king in
Westeros gets murdered and Jaime just
doesn't care about any of it or at least
he pretends not to care now he's not an
alcoholic like Tyrion is so he mostly
numbs himself by having sex with Cersei
with that in mind let's take a quick
poll do you think that in books 1
through 3 or in seasons 1 through 3
Jaime is aware that series children
belong to him and if he does do you
think he cares because of the way the
POV chapters are written in the books
and because of the show kind of limits
the amount of scenes each actor gets
they don't really explicitly state
whether or not he knows that Joffrey is
his son or that Circe's other children
belong to him to just like Lois Lane
probably knew who Superman was the whole
time I'm guessing that Jaime did pretty
much know that these children were his
and just chose to ignore that fact but
his character really hits that turning
point in season 3 you all know the
moment I'm talking about so I won't
mention it specifically here in case
people haven't seen it yet it's pretty
big but he basically goes on to try and
reclaim his honor after this but it's
not so much the actual event that
changes his character it's really his
time with Brienne in season 3 and he
pretty much does spend most of his time
with Brienne in this season so she
starts to rub off on him and she's one
of the most honorable characters in the
show
Brienne really does kind of help him
find his honor in a bear pit but the
really interesting thing about his
characters is that that was not the
first time that he said stop nope no
more remember there's a reason why he's
called the Kingslayer and it
you ever wondered if your King tells you
that he's going to murder everyone
around you in an orgy of green flame
it's totally okay to murder him so I'm
guessing that even if they do cut out a
lot of the moments that his character
has in books three and books four during
season 4 on the show that most of his
character beats will still be there so
remember at the end of season 3 he's
back in King's Landing now but I'm
really interested to see how his
relationship with Cersei is going to
change now that he's trying to reclaim
his honor he's really just on the path
it's not like he rescues Brienne and
that bear pit and that he's just
automatically a good person now he's
basically on the path to becoming a good
person so that's only going to continue
in season 4 don't be surprised if the
twincest is at an end and remembered the
Brienne actually came back to King's
Landing with him too and while they were
kind of like one character for most of
season 3 I'm gonna be really bummed to
see them kind of depart I'm assuming now
that they're both back in King's Landing
that a lot of their scenes will be a
part now so it's really hard to know
what the show is going to do with her
now but even though they didn't become
an actual couple in the show I do kind
of feel like they were a really good
emotional couple here's another really
awesome poll in the comments below
list your favorite couples on the show
that never actually became couples like
Sansa and the Hound or Joffrey in this
crossbow seriously don't you think the
Joffrey would totally marry his crossbow
if he could or maybe a severed head so
in my first preview for season four for
Tyrion I asked you guys to let me know
which characters you wanted to talk
about first and overwhelmingly you
listed a ton of the main cast members
like Arya Sansa the Hound
Littlefinger so by popular demand my
next preview will be for Arya that will
post on Friday be sure to subscribe to
get that video I'm also working on a
preview for Supernatural season 9 and
since that show is going to air at the
same time as arrow whenever I do a
supernatural video I'll try to do an
arrow video as well too I'm also working
on another preview for Doctor Who they
just made a really big announcement for
series 8 thank you so much to Nerdist
for forming an alliance with me to win a
game of YouTube's if you guys really
want to help me out please like and
share this video you can click here to
get part 1 of my Game of Thrones Season
4 preview and you can click here to get
that arya preview on friday i'll have
the link whenever i post that video
thank you so much for helping me get to
20,000 subscribers so fast you guys are
all awesome high fives